so that intro clip made absolutely no
sense to anybody
but me let me fill you in the title of
my thesis
was called launch day it was all about
interplanetary space travel
and it was filled with a lot of errors
[Music]
what's going on guys my name is david
tomic and welcome back to the channel
so i picked up my thesis the other day
and quickly read through it and i
thought
i've learned a lot since i submitted
this project and i wish i knew these
things
when i was actually at university so i
thought i'd create this video today to
help you guys
not make the same mistakes i did so
launch day in itself as a thesis started
very simply it started by
going through the generic requirements
of a thesis submission now this is where
it gets
really bad and i think i didn't
articulate it properly
i went through broke it down how i
designed it how i got to there
how the materials work and yes that it
does work in this situation
but then i started showing 3d renders of
the final product that made absolutely
no sense
first of all the first render is a 3d
cross section
of the entry statement which houses the
first shuttle
ever launched into space as a museum
masterpiece but
the whole idea is to wrap around and
meander all the way up
which doesn't comply with any of the
australian building standards
it is a very long meandering ramp that
would take you forever as a journey
nobody would actually appreciate it and
you'd just be looking at the one space
shuttle over and over again
as you went up those three levels but
then i didn't explain
why that section looked like that why it
was in a different shape
why there was fins hugging and wrapping
the sides of it and then turned into
what
now looks like a motorcycle helmet god
knows what it actually was meant to be
so there was a lot of elements that
truly were missed there
from a constructability point of view
and it was just
a pretty image the one good thing i did
was do an exploded axometric
and then also showcased the levels and
the schedule
of works throughout this building but i
never went through and broke down those
floor plans individually
i had this huge building that had so
much space so much potential
but yet i never showcased any of it i
think i must have started running out of
time or something because
looking back on it now i could have
designed this incredible museum that had
all these historical elements
and a hotel that was luxurious and had
gardens and everything and there could
have been some amazing documentation
here
but as a student i guess i was very
limited in time i was very limited in
ability
i was limited in knowledge so looking
back and not taking that opportunity to
actually create
makes me quite sad after explaining
those areas very quickly i went to a
quick floor section 3d looking thing
of how that museum work which again
makes absolutely no sense because
it was just non-compliant non-functional
and just
dumb now looking back at it i'm allowed
to say it because mine
and then i ended the project pretty
quickly by showing a picture of launch
tower one again
which didn't symbolize anything i don't
think i talked it through enough
i didn't explain nearly enough
so there was no explanation of why the
building wrapped and meandered down to
the ground
why that helmet wrapped and meandered
back down to the ground while i was
hugging the rocket
i don't think i explained that
critically anywhere and there was so
many elements of how i could explain
that
again i think it was limited time
limited knowledge
but looking back it would have been good
just to
decipher this picture better and
actually annotate it some more and give
some more context
because at the moment it's just a pretty
picture and it doesn't tell me anything
the next image is a bit better it breaks
down kind of the structure and
what's around but looking at it again it
isn't actually feasible you have people
running around
a rocket which is usually a highly
classified area
kids running around the lawn next to
some very sharp very expensive objects
trees everywhere which would have burnt
in an instant
yeah i didn't didn't think that render
through at all that was
just bad the only thing that i did
really really well was the emotive
journey at the end and showcasing the
astronauts
leaving earth into the travel pod
and it was articulating that through an
aperture slowly closing and
disappearing earth and only leaving the
astronauts in their own environment
so as that aperture closed more and more
astronauts came in and became darker and
darker
i think i articulated that scene well as
what i wanted to
actually showcase the emotion of the
journey and
those three pictures are probably all i
did
really well throughout this thesis so
looking back on that that was a bit of a
emotional roller coaster i think that
there is a lot to learn
from looking back at your own work so if
you're in third or fourth year for
example go back and look at your first
year's worth of work and go
wow i've progressed so much i missed
this i missed that i didn't do this i
didn't do that
and remember those elements that you
forgot and do them in your next project
because there's a good chance
you aren't still doing them now you
might know the information but you're
not doing it
so all the mistakes that i've made in
this thesis project
could have very simply been avoided if i
just
asked more questions did more research
did more work
and i think not going back and just
reviewing and reflecting and stepping
away for a minute
and going that doesn't make sense why
did i do that
why didn't i do this really let me down
in the long run
so if you are submitting your thesis and
submitting your final project
it is a long haul it is 12 months worth
of hard work
but at the end of the day it is
something that is very rewarding
anyway that's all for me today guys
thank you so much for watching i hope
you enjoyed the video
it was a lot longer than usual but it is
what it is
if you enjoy that sort of content and
want to see more architecture related
videos make sure you smash that
subscribe button down below
and as always i will see you very
shortly